yeah i actually think like  there's a difference in the way there's  a fundamental difference in the way  that men and women view god  and  that's why there's so many women in the  church this is my hypothesis right  so  women are attracted to powerful men  and god is the most powerful man  that's why you hear  that's interesting and that is why  you'll hear women say ah i don't need a  man i've got jesus  you've heard women i've heard women say  that you know what and it's like i don't  i don't hear men say that men don't say  oh i'm i'm all right i don't need a wife  i've got jesus it's like that's the yeah  yeah but that's like that's my theory  like my theory is we have a fundamental  difference whether us consciously or  subconsciously in the way in which we  view god because god is the most  powerful man and women are attracted to  powerful men so here's my question  though so i'm attracted to jesus  i don't know i don't know the inner  workings of the psychology around it but